i don't know i can kind of go i can kind
of go either way volcano or guitar oh
the volcano if they were going to do
something to the fountains at bellagio
i'd be like okay that would get you
right eight news now digital team maybe
we can put up a poll i think so
which way you're gonna go you're going
rock and roll you go in natural volcano
i'm saying volcano because when i used
to watch the boxing matches with my dad
from washington state they would show
the volcano because all the boxing
matches would occur
las vegas
was your dad a boxing fan oh he's a huge
part of that
huge
generation of men love boxing
might as well and i can't even box
but huge boxing fan and i remember the
volcano growing up so yeah gotta keep it
live look outside right now and there's
a look at the mirage guys right now
great shot of the mirage the background
there the wind treasure island good
looking day today 62 degrees our
official high a couple degrees above
normal or 59 degrees i want to compare
that temperature comparison to houston
here's what's interesting houston was
warmer than us today of course 82
degrees but tomorrow
their high is going to be 46 degrees
82 to 46 tomorrow in houston texas wow
58 centennial hills right now along with
sky canyon these are our local
neighborhoods 61 spring valley 60 even
for north las vegas 65 for sunrise manor
along with whitney ranch mountain's edge
at 60 degrees we're at 60 for our 63 for
nellis 53 boulder city
55 for prompt and 64 currently for
lafayette so bother for you again in
laughlin radar network again not picking
up any precip any showers here nothing
not even in southeast california do see
a few rain drops still sticking around
eastern portions of arizona as that low
continues to move off towards the east
so in its wake nothing here however see
this ridge here out in the pacific well
we're on what we call the eastern flanks
of that ridge and then we'll see
disturbances right down this part of the
jet stream and that will increase this
winds for us so wind forecast does show
winds will pick up a little tonight and
then be a little breezy tomorrow but
you'll see the colors here right here in
your neighborhoods all light up that's
friday okay so that's when we'll get
those very gusty winds on friday and
also saturday so here's what to expect
there is a lakewood advisory that starts
at 4 am all the way until 4 pm we will
have gusts up to 40 at the lake choppy
waves up to 2 feet possible so hazardous
boating not only tomorrow but also for
your weekend too 43 overnight 61
tomorrow increasing those winds sunny
and breezy for tomorrow here's a look at
your eight day forecast the strongest
wind day is going to be on friday and
saturday like we talked about
temperatures in the low 60s next week
looking nice mid 60s on monday i'll tell
you what i'm not doing this weekend
is going boating for sure yeah too
choppy out there when you have winds
like that you get really high water
there are people are going to do it
anyways wear the life vests i heard that
you're a great skier so if you're a
great water skier i i like water skiing
can you do one ski oh easy slalom yeah
that's a lot of fun no skis no ski
no skis
chris
no i love it
you know that's what i love the golden
knights how about that segment you're
talking about these golden lights in the
nhs we're gonna try to make up a ton of
games here during